isn't tampa where you um got a three
four
three for one two for one i thought you
said three i never got a three
congratulations thank you that's pretty
impressive feat tampa was the only time
i don't know if i should talk about it
sometimes it's okay no i will um tampa
was the only city where i
made love to two women
in one day okay wow and it was they
didn't know about each other right right
it was one of those things where
because i've heard like
other comments talk about you know i
mean i don't want to name names but i
know dudes that do it but it was just
like i just never thought it was in my
skill set
and um what kind of skill is that yeah
yeah what skill sets no i mean just like
being desired in that way
for me like every time like before
kalila every time i would be with a girl
to be like
this is a miracle like i won the lottery
right but that day was like a magical
day where um where it happened twice
well i had to save nut juice
how long is your um refractory period
usually a week but usually a week but
yeah yeah but for that time i um
it was like
stepped up wow like i i shot
shot again you know what i mean yeah it
was pretty cool yeah but that's never
happened before or after i mean that's
really just a just a matter of math and
averages if you are
if you're a person who's uh uh you know
engaged in coitus with a partner let's
say
five times uh five uh times yearly uh
and three of them happen in one day that
is just the way it could be all five or
it could be spread out every other month
um yeah but yeah i don't think that's uh
i don't think that has i don't know that
you can brag about that just sort of i
wasn't bragging it was just a story that
i brought up my friend yeah it's it is
yes it does feel good though no it it
yeah it means that there's more than uh
a few hours in the day to you you there
was that and then you went off and you
you probably had you know yet you went
to eat somewhere
and then no it was one of those things
where and someone said someone left the
hotel okay and then an hour later
somebody came up wow yeah an hour wow
like an hour hour and a half yeah yeah
it was pretty cool that's pressure yeah
i would have thought that it was uh two
organic situations happening separately
like you are
ha you have like you're in a
relationship previous to kalila and
uh she comes out with you to like you're
doing a show or you're shooting
something out in florida and it's like
come with me we're going to do this
thing okay great yeah or a weekend in
tampa doing stand-up and then you have a
horrible fight and you split up and she
leaves and you guys are screaming at
each other in the lobby of the hotel
and then you know the gal at the at the
uh stand the receptionist the
receptionist yeah yeah like no one's
posing no one calls it the stand
whatever that's what i call it that's
what i call it in canada so you have to
respect that
um and then you know you guys have just
been having like some late night chats
over those little tins of pringles or at
least i do yeah
and then uh she's like couldn't help but
notice you were screaming your head off
at that person yeah everybody today how
about i come up uh later and we hang out
and you know no press no just talk yeah
yeah but that does sound more organic
yeah that sounds organic but that's
never i've never
been to like a restaurant or
you know at a hotel at the stand yeah
and has had the lady working at the
stand go let's hook up i they have to
i've always
had to have somebody know me already who
i am yes yeah that that that happens a
lot with sex you know the person for a
while no no
no fed
they have to know that i'm a comedian
and whatnot oh in order to want to have
sex with you for uh because all reasons
are other than physical this is what
yeah yeah all right we know who you are
yeah yeah yeah
so um who you sing now same girl uh i am
engaged to uh my gal yeah
yeah
hey cheers thanks yeah molly and i have
been together for like three years and
you guys have two dogs one of which you
found in the middle of a freeway two
dogs yeah molly's had her little dog
ronnie for like years she's like 11
years old and then uh yeah a couple
years ago during the pandemic
she's originally from northern
california we're driving back to l.a and
to make a long story short we pulled
over to get gas like halfway this little
town